[Musique]
évidemment ici culture bonne humeur on
est ensemble tous les mercredis de 20h à
21h en direct bienvenue dans l'émission
Vy P sur TV 78 consacré aux
personnalités du territoire yvelinois et
ce soir on va mettre en lumière n'ont
pas une personnalité mais une émission
une émission phare dans le panorama des
radios associatives locales c'est
l'antisèche elle a lieu tous les
mercredis de 20h à 21h sur les ondes de
marmite FM 88.4 et elle entame sa
septième saison elle a déjà entamé une
émission qui a été créée en 2017 et pour
en parler on a quatre invités avec nous
on a Julien Thomas clair et Ronan
bonsoir à tous les quatre alors juste
pour vous présenter Julien denerveau
animateur et producteur Thomas Salazar
réalisateur et chroniqueur Claire's
Souidi assistante production et
chroniqueuse et enfin Ronan gueudon
c'est bien gueudon c'est Guédon voilà
je n'avais pas le bon nom mais c'est pas
grave j'ai ma apprentissage qui n'était
pas à jour visiblement qui est
technicien monteur et chroniqueur alors
ces quatre personnes de l'équipe mais
Julien c'est une équipe un peu plus
complète il y a un peu plus de monde
dans cette équipe de l'antisèche oui
parce que l'anti-sèches c'est l'émission
que personne
évidemment c'est le slogan de l'émission
et donc on a aussi Sophie Coraline qui
nous a rejoint cette année on a Kévin on
a également Marie et plein d'autres on
pourrait citer une dizaine de noms
encore plein de chroniqueurs animatrices
animateurs qui sont passés par
l'émission avec des chroniques un peu
diverses et variées chacun avec leur
style donc l'émission que personne ne
sèche ça c'est le slogan le concept de
l'émission C'est un rendez-vous décalé
apprendre tout en s'amusant c'est ça
l'idée avec de la bonne humeur c'est le
maître mot oui c'est ça l'idée l'idée
c'est on va apprendre on va passer enfin
on va on va décompresser voilà on va se
faire une petite soupape de
décompression le mercredi soir entre 20h
et 21h on va découvrir des artistes
locaux on va apprendre plein de choses
sur la culture et surtout je pense qu'on
apprendre des choses qu'on entend pas
partout dans les médias et voilà et
c'est ça l'idée c'est de passer un bon
moment et de retenir des choses qu'on
peut raconter par exemple le lendemain
la machine à café c'est ça aussi l'idée
alors claire tu avais dit dans un
reportage qu'on avait consacré à
l'émission anti-sèches l'idée c'est de
poser son cerveau est-ce que tu peux
préciser voilà d'emblée d'emblée on
commence avec avec les petits dossiers
mais c'est quoi l'idée poser son cerveau
c'est à dire déconnecter comme le disait
comme le disait Julien et voilà
apprendre en s'amusant c'est c'est
complètement ça c'est à dire que ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est qu'en fait
on apprend mais en fait on sent même pas
compte qu'on qu'on apprend c'est
vraiment c'est du divertissement c'est
on s'amuse en fait tout simplement
derrière l'émission c'est joli prod
c'est l'association jolie prod on peut
dire aussi un mot sur jolyprote c'est
quoi joli prod alors jolie prod c'est
une association yvelinoise qui
accompagne développe des projets
culturels qui est là pour promouvoir la
culture locale et mettre en réseau des
amateurs et des professionnels et bien
l'anti sèche c'est ça reprend un petit
peu tout ça aussi à travers cette
émission on a la chance de pouvoir être
en partenariat avec des salles de
spectacle de l'agglomération pour offrir
des places aux auditeurs et auditrices
mais également on a un partenariat qui
est très fort avec marmite FM qui nous
permet de faire cette émission toutes
les semaines qui nous fait confiance qui
nous accompagne sur ce projet et voilà
et donc là le lien entre les amateurs et
les professionnels existent vraiment et
voilà un joli prod c'est ça tout
simplement
si on peut faire un petit tour de micro
Thomas nous raconter un peu vos missions
alors je vous ai présenté mais voilà
quels sont tes missions sur sur cette
émission l'antisèche alors sur
l'antisèche du coup coup moi je suis
chroniqueur j'ai une chronique en fait
sur sur le cinéma qui s'appelle le
Making Thomas en fait on parle un petit
peu des anecdotes sur les tournages des
des films les plus connus comme les plus
insolites aussi et notamment il faut
aussi je suis réalisateur voilà c'est à
dire que que je réalise l'émission je
suis derrière les manettes quoi j'allume
j'allume le micro parce que c'est vrai
je vais présenter vous avez plusieurs
missions chacun j'ai envie de dire sur
sur cette émission oui effectivement bah
c'est ça qui est ça qui est intéressant
aussi en fait c'est que c'est que le
monde de la radio on l'explore un peu en
en sont en comble j'avais envie de dire
mais mais voilà on l'explore et chacun
vraiment
développe ce qu'il intéresse et peut
développer on peut développer beaucoup
de choses sur Julien oui pour compléter
ce que dit Thomas c'est ça on apprend à
faire de la radio ensemble aussi
certains sont professionnels de la radio
d'autres non et ils apprennent avec eux
c'est aussi ça il y a cette passion pour
la culture qui nous unit tous on est
tous artistes et à côté il y a cette
passion pour la radio c'est que certains
ont découvert en prenant le micro pour
la première fois et d'autres comme
Thomas par exemple qui m'accompagne
depuis ces 15 ans déjà même avant même
14 ans ou lui vraiment tu as passé
beaucoup d'étapes dans cette émission
avec des parts ils étaient deux devoirs
à la radio il va passer son bac après la
radio et maintenant il réalise une
mission un mariage peut-être
il y a un petit côté Truman Show dans
cette émission on me suit un petit peu
trop dans ma vie privée du coup si on
peut continuer sur la mission toi tu
anime cette bande c'est un peu le on va
dire le passage de relais dans dans
toute cette bande oui bah c'est ça cette
mission d'animer et de coordonner toutes
les missions que ça soit du conducteur à
l'organisation des émissions aux
recherches de partenariat recherche
d'invités voilà et coordonnées avec avec
toute l'équipe leurs chroniques à chaque
fois s'il y a une question je suis
disponible pour qu'on m'appelle pour
pour vérifier le sujet ou du moins
comment quelle langue on peut donner à
son sujet etc et voilà donc j'ai ce rôle
de liant on va dire et voilà mais c'est
une émission avant tout d'équipe sans
tout le monde il y a pas d'antisèches en
fait on pourrait pas faire l'anti-sèches
tout seul c'est pas possible du coup bah
voilà c'est un véritable travail
d'équipe avec des chroniques de chacun
et surtout il y a je pense qui est ce
qui est très important qu'on pourrait
rajouter c'est la bonne humeur sans
toute cette bonne humeur et cette
bienveillance qui a entre nous dans
l'émission mais aussi en dehors de
l'émission on pourrait pas donner ce
contenu là à l'antenne je pense que
c'est quelque chose d'assez important
sur son rôle clair assistant de
production chroniqueuse également sur
sur l'émission l'antisèche oui tout à
fait bah du coup moi mes chroniques
c'est je fais un marque-page où je parle
donc de de littérature je parle d'oeuf
que j'ai lu voilà et à côté je fais le
saviez-vous où je parle de petites infos
insolites voilà que je dégote c'est ma
toute première chronique celle-là et
sur le côté assistante de production en
fait ça fait quelques temps ou moi je
travaille vraiment sur la production de
l'émission ou sur le contenu sur la
façon où on va parler voilà traiter nos
sujets ou parler aux artistes et tout ça
en fait on en parle beaucoup en équipe
mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai pris ce
rôle là depuis depuis quelques temps
maintenant voilà parler de tout ça n'a
pas encore entendu Ronan guédoule au
moins une fois bien merci merci donc
technicien sur cette émission on était
aussi plusieurs rôles tu fais aussi la
chronique ouais c'est ça technicien
chroniqueur technicien donc en fait
quand Julien a besoin de de son ou genre
de choses il m'appelle on en parle un
petit peu avant tout ce qui est sorti la
musique etc et même après pour les
podcasts il y a des choses à rajouter
voilà on discute s'il y a des petits
questions techniques pour les téléphones
etc en gros c'est c'est pour moi et
comment tu es arrivé toi dans cette
émission qu'est-ce qui t'a attiré
qu'est-ce qui te plaît aujourd'hui et en
fait bah c'est naturellement c'est que
je suis arrivé à m'embêter FM en tant
que technicien voilà en fait c'est mon
travail de base et en fait bah le fil en
aiguille je me suis retrouvé à les voir
un petit peu ce que ça donnait etc donc
je suis pris au jeu et je passais
chroniqueur voilà et quel type de
chronique du coup je fais des chroniques
jeux vidéo donc sur la pratique et sur
les jeux vidéo en même en fait j'essaie
de montrer un petit peu qu'il y a plein
de choses que qu'il y a autour des jeux
vidéo qui sont cool à découvrir et à
faire et que c'est pas juste dans hobby
pardon qui est réservé à aux jeunes ou
jeunes adultes etc c'est vraiment pour
tout le monde et voilà donc des
chroniques des invités si on revient sur
la forme c'est c'est une heure
d'émission c'est ça avec Chronique
invités oui voilà c'est ça c'est une
heure d'émission où l'invité est mêler
au coeur des chroniques on va dire on
adapte à chaque fois notre émission à
l'invité donc ça soit n'importe quel
artiste local ou une personne un peu
plus connue va rester en général une
heure avec nous en fonction de son temps
mais c'est très souvent une heure c'est
jamais avoir plus on va dire voilà et
l'idée c'est de travailler de faire
ressortir le faire la promotion de cet
artiste mais également enfin de son
spectacle où l'événement qui vient
présenter mais c'est également axé sur
son côté humain et voilà et montrer que
bah oui il est peut-être artiste connu
ou pas connu mais c'est quelqu'un comme
nous finalement et du coup on va on va
s'amuser ensemble tout en apprenant des
choses comme on disait et voilà je sais
plus si c'est ça la question oui mais
c'était ça c'était la forme mais le
concept aussi on est revenu sur le
concept pour que cette émission si soit
possible c'est le travail de bénévole
comment ça se prépare comment vous
organisez entre vous dans la semaine
pour produire une heure d'émission
comment ça s'articule tout ça alors
justement une heure on croirait que
c'est pas beaucoup mais comme on est
bénévole on travaille le soir on
travaille le week-end et c'est
énormément d'organisation et
d'anticipation c'est une véritable
gestion de projet qu'on mène quand c'est
l'été on travaille la saison d'après
voir avant même là je sais que depuis
cet été je travaille sur les éléments de
Noël par exemple bref c'est tout ce
travail de saison
est très très chronophage on va dire
mais c'est un vrai plaisir parce que le
notre mission à tous enfin pas notre
mission mais notre on va dire notre
objectif notre consécration en fait de
tout ce travail c'est le mercredi c'est
c'est cette petite heure qui des fois
bah un peu plus loin avec des
exclusivités en podcast alors l'émission
a été créée en 2017 je disais elle va
entamé déjà même ça ça septième saison
quelle était l'idée à la base pourquoi
la voix imaginée pourquoi l'avoir créé
c'est pas Thomas ou Julien ou peut-être
quelqu'un d'autre claire Thomas tu veux
tu veux répondre à cette question
je pense que je pense que la genèse de
cette émission je vais expliquer comme
moi je l'ai vécu oui j'avais 14 ans
j'étais dans mon canapé et Julien qui
est un ami de de la famille
qui est la famille même on pourrait dire
me dit ouais parce que moi j'étais
passionné de radio quand tu étais quand
j'étais tout petit je m'enregistrais
dans ma chambre sur mon ordinateur
comme ça en disant n'importe quoi et euh
et Julien me dit ouais j'ai un j'ai un
concept d'émission Emma il m'a il m'a
pitché l'antisèche j'ai adoré cette idée
en fait c'était cette idée de de choses
justement en même temps divertissant en
même temps culturel
et et de pouvoir aller sur une radio
comme marmite FM quand on a 14 ans quand
on a 14 ans c'est franchement c'est pas
mal mais je pense que celui qui peut
mieux raconter la Genèse ça c'est Julien
ouais effectivement bah la genèse de ce
projet elle remonte à très loin à peu
près quand j'avais 8 ans j'ai dit que je
voulais faire de la télé ou de la radio
voilà entre temps j'ai fait du cinéma du
théâtre et un jour j'ai découvert une
affiche dans mon université qui est d'un
journaliste local ici sur marmite FM qui
s'appelle nouradin Anne qui est voilà
qui était comme ça avec son doigt et qui
a dit viens faire la radio et en gros
bah de là j'ai fait un atelier dans les
locaux de TV 78 à l'époque
voilà on peut le on peut on peut le dire
et ensuite j'ai ma passion pour la radio
est véritablement née j'ai fait une
formation de radio et à la fin de cette
formation je me suis dit ok ce qui est
génial c'est que là je suis dans une
région qui a une forte identité moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est qu'on crée cette
identité dans notre région à nous et
avec un programme
un programme PHARE enfin d'enfer un
programme PHARE comme on pourrait
écouter une grande matinale sur une
grande radio bah là ça serait plus une
grande Paradise puisqu'on est un peu
plus tard que le drive mais voilà l'idée
c'était ça c'est de créer ce rendez-vous
pour les Yvelinois et sur cette radio là
qui est marmite FM qui a déjà 20 ans je
crois c'est ça et donc pour l'anti sèche
c'est 6 saisons passées une septième qui
a commencé il y a forcément des
meilleurs moments des anecdotes qui vous
viennent on va faire aussi un tour de
micro pour vous nous racontiez vos
meilleurs moments vos anecdotes
peut-être des choses qui vous reviennent
en tête claire
non tu abuses tu abuses parce que ce
moment était merveilleux en fait on a
mais tant pis pour toi je te le vol
fallait pas me le dire
un super moment alors il était pas à la
radio même il était en off c'est
justement l'année dernière où en fait on
a on a créé cette idée de la grande
hotte de Noël avec Thomas et Julien qui
est né complètement d'un délire mais
vraiment c'est à dire qu'on est sorti de
l'émission et on s'est dit mais faut
absolument on voulait on voulait faire
un en fait on était après le covid et on
s'est dit on veut on veut revenir un peu
en force sur notamment les jeux concours
et tout ça et donc on s'est dit mais si
on offrait plusieurs places de spectacle
comme on le fait d'habitude mais en même
temps pour une fois et on tient ouais ce
serait super il y a de Noël qui arrive
Noël était dans trois semaines ouais
ouais ce serait bien si Noël qui arrive
on se fait une grande hotte et là c'est
parti en vrille
on a fait une hotte tous les
chroniqueurs ont dû faire des cadeaux
enfin c'était c'était l'idée c'était
super en trois semaines c'est un peu
short
la partie la plus fun c'était justement
c'était ce soir qu'on a fait l'émission
spéciale Noël ou on s'est un petit peu
tous enflammé et je me suis retrouvé à
les livrer le gagnant chez lui alors
c'était à Montigny la gagnante avec les
trottinettes de la ville de
Saint-Quentin qu'on avait un peu
customisé en Rennes donc déguisé en la
vidéo et sur le facebook de l'anti sèche
alors du coup déguisé en Père Noël avec
une hotte très lourde
à traverser on est parti bah à Montigny
aéro dans ton anecdote
du Père Noël mais je vais changer du
coup
ça bon mais en souvenir ça doit être
avec l'interview de Pépé du groupe de
luxe c'est la première fois que j'avais
l'occasion interviewer un artiste comme
ça et c'était vraiment un super moment
il était hyper accessible on a bien
rigolé avec lui et même c'était hyper
intéressant donc sincèrement un souvenir
je pense Julien l'émission spéciale Noël
peut-être aussi
effectivement ça fait partie des bons
souvenirs après en cette saison des
souvenirs il y en a énormément moi je
dirais j'ai deux choses un de mes
meilleurs souvenirs c'est en fait chaque
mercredi soir à la fin de l'émission
c'est à dire que enfin on a mais oui
parce que en fait on a mis en vraiment
en oeuvre ce qu'on a imaginé pendant une
semaine c'est comme quand vous êtes un
artiste vous montez un spectacle et bien
voilà à la fin de l'année où six mois
après quand vous avez le spectacle qui
est monté vous l'avez joué et ça laisse
quelque chose une satisfaction voilà et
donc ça à chaque fin d'émission j'ai
cette petite cette petite émotion on va
dire après il y a un très très grand
souvenir que je trouve c'est une superbe
anecdote une fois je vais dans un
commerce pour acheter bah voilà je vais
dans un commerce on va pas dire quoi et
le commerçant
oui j'ai découvert une émission etc donc
en fait la personne me raconte il est
très fier d'avoir découvert cette
émission très content franchement c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut que j'écoute et
donc je lui en demande un peu plus et là
il me donne l'horaire et la station et
là je dis bah écoute je suis désolé mais
c'est moi qui fait l'émission et avec
l'équipe et voilà et donc ça c'est un
super souvenir et ça arrive de temps en
temps on va dire qu'il y a des il y a
des gens qu'on ne sait pas qui nous
écoutent et qui nous en parle on vous
écoute on entend vos voix et maintenant
on a vu aussi vos visages peut-être dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
parce qu'il y a les affiches qu'on a pu
voir sur les abribus sur tout tous les
éléments d'affichage à 50 ans pour cette
7e saison c'est quoi les objectifs de la
saison ce qu'il y a des nouveautés ce
qu'il y a des idées d'invité
des objectifs d'inviter
alors déjà on remerciera 51 Yvelines de
nous avoir aidés sur cette campagne
d'affichage effectivement c'est très
drôle de se voir dans les villes
mais voilà il y a toute l'équipe on est
d'ailleurs sur un canapé comme
aujourd'hui donc allez-y apprenez vous
en photo si vous voyez la photo faites
un selfie rajoutez vous dans l'équipe on
va dire voilà les objectifs c'est
surtout d'être vu par par les habitants
et surtout écouter voilà vous que vous
que le 5 habitants ou chaque artiste
comprenne que c'est son moment à lui qui
peut venir dans cette émission pour
présenter son événement promouvoir son
album promouvoir sa pièce de théâtre etc
il faut juste nous contacter sur la page
Facebook ou sur le compte Instagram de
de l'émission voilà ça l'objectif c'est
de faire connaître un peu plus notre
travail et cette émission parce que ça
fait 7 saisons qu'on l'a fait tous
ensemble qu'on s'éclate et je pense à le
mérite d'exister aux oreilles de tout le
monde voilà après vous parliez d'inviter
des invités là je sais qu'on est calé
jusqu'à la fin de la saison avec des
artistes locaux euh voilà qui font des
premières parties dans les salles
culturelles de l'agglomération ou qui
ont des spectacles pareil dans l'agglo
ou ailleurs dans les Yvelines notamment
voilà il y a d'autres projets d'invité
et comme par exemple ce soir c'est
Olivia Ruiz qui sera avec nous ça fait
partie des opérations qu'on peut faire
avec les salles aussi avoir des invités
un peu plus guest et cette année petite
nouveauté quand même on va essayer de
faire un de venir vous rencontrer
d'aller sur le terrain d'aller sur le
terrain avec un studio pour faire des
émissions vraiment un peu plus spéciales
délocaliser donc Olivier russe qui s'est
produit te à la Maurice de trappe qui va
se produire à la Maurice de trappe
claire oui juste nouveautés je voulais
rajouter un tout petit truc on a une
petite nouveauté mine de rien cette
saison qui je pense c'est intéressant à
dire on a une nouvelle chroniqueuse
aussi et du coup une nouvelle chronique
en fait ça ça change régulièrement
toutes les saisons on a souvent des
nouvelles chroniques de ce que notre
chroniqueur actuel et là on a une
nouvelle chroniqueuse qui s'appelle
coranine et qui fait une nouvelle
chronique sur la musique pardon très
rapidement qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter dernière question
cette saison de plus du coup
[Rires]
peut-être qu'on verra le mariage en
direct
toutes les étapes de la vie de Thomas
Salazar
c'est vrai c'est vrai non qu'est-ce
qu'on peut nous souhaiter oui c'est ça
plein de cette saison ça serait beau
évidemment surtout on peut nous
souhaiter d'être encore plus écouté
qu'on est déjà et de bouquets encore
plus notre emploi du temps avec tous les
artistes du territoire c'est ça c'est de
faire d'agrandir la famille de
l'antisèche parce que l'antisèche c'est
l'émission que personne
et c'est tous les mercredis soirs donc
de 20h à 21h sur les ondes de marmite FM
88.4 en podcast aussi on peut vous
réécouter oui tout à fait sur marmite
fm.fr c'est le monsieur qui est là Ronan
qui est qui met tous les podcasts en
ligne et bien merci Ronan merci Julien
merci Claire merci Thomas je le rappelle
un marmite FM donc il diffuse tout les
mercredis soirs de 20h à 21h cette
émission l'anti-sèche c'est la fin de ce
V YP merci de nous avoir suivi
l'émission aussi à revoir leur en
podcast mais en replay sur notre site
Internet TV 78.com belle soirée à tous
merci
[Musique]